messages of support and hope pouring out
tonight after raiders player carl nasib
is the first active nfl player
to publicly come out his game in fact
espn is now reporting that his jersey is
the top
seller in the fanatics network victoria
saha takes a look at how his message is
helping las vegas youth
in the lgbtq community i want to take a
quick moment to say that i'm gay karl
nasib's message
giving courage to the many las vegas
youth in the lgbtq community
who might be worried about being
accepted i was so
proud and happy like it made me feel
happy to know that
he could just come out and say this is
who he is and he was happy of who he was
butler castelleron is just 13 years old
but tells me she knew from the age of
nine she was gay from listening to kids
at school whose parents were
also not entirely friendly with it i was
a little more
i was a little worried her 11-year-old
brother kai
was born as mia but quickly realized
being a female it didn't seem right to
him
i was just so nervous all the time so
having an nfl player like nasib come out
inspired the siblings with their
identity you can truly be who you are
and still do sports and play football
no matter what your sexuality or your
gender identity is their mother hopes
naseb's message will open the doors to
more acceptance
coming out and feeling like he
authentically can live his life
has really given an example for both of
my children
that there are just not not a lot of
limits left anymore executive director
of the nevada alliance for student
diversity says
suicides can decrease by 40 percent in
lgbtq youth
if there is at least one supportive
adult in their life
i teared up a little bit when i watched
his video because i know
how many lives that will change and you
know there are so
many young kids out there that
are just desperate for and you know an
opportunity to
be authentic hernandez's group offers
support to both lgbtq youth
as well as their parents victoria saha 8
news now